thanks to the work of some very fine
dramatists the Netflix adaptation of the
series of unfortunate events novels has
been absolutely fantastic a word which
here means full of very frightening
danger various fakery disguises and very
fitting definitions yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm John and today I'm exploring
12 of the biggest differences between
the unfortunate events TV series and the
original books spoilers ahead for the
show and the novel's while the books are
rather cryptic about the identity the
taxi driver who offers to take the
bolars away from the Hotel de new Monde
after Joey's death by harpoon the TV
shows much much clearer pilots Klaus and
sunny Baudelaire
my name is Lemony Snicket in the novels
the children couldn't see the taxi
drivers face in the darkness just the
tip of a lit cigarette of course even
before season 3 Lemony was already more
involved and present in the action of
the Netflix series compared to the books
when we hear uncle Monty tell the
children I promise you no harm will come
to you in the reptile room we should be
on guard for the unpleasant arrival of
dramatic irony but it was great to
finally see the bowlers and on orator
meet in the penultimate parallel sides
frankly the whole cast has been a joy to
watch throughout the series with Patrick
Warburton fantastic as Lemony Snicket
perfectly capturing his deadpan nature
one character who doesn't make it from
the books into the TV show is captain
woody shion's
in season 3 we just see a prominently
placed portrait of him as well as a
photograph belonging to a stepdaughter
Fiona who reveals that widdershins left
one day to answer a distress call from a
manatee and never came back the TV
series combines parts of Fiona's
character from the grim grotto book with
aspects of a stepfathers role as captain
of the Queequeg and we do hear
widdershins voice in the finale showing
that he is indeed still alive
Netflix make several more changes to the
grim Grotto storyline for example Olaf
finds the Queequeg earlier in the show
than he does in the books and he forces
the Bo dealers to visit the gorgonian
grotto whereas in the books he turns up
after the orphans return from the grotto
with Fiona who doesn't accompany them
there in the TV show and in the books
Phil goes missing part way through the
story along with Captain Widow shion's
the show also reveals how the
hook-handed Man aka Fernald lost both
his hands which isn't confirmed in the
novel's though it has been a fan theory
I suspect these various changes were
made to condense the action highlight
the Baudelaire self-reliance by removing
an adult's guardian figure as well as
give fans some closure on their theories
because the show's writers wanted Count
Olaf to end season 2 and begin season 3
on a triumphant note they decided to
keep his villainous associates alive
even though several of them are killed
off earlier in the books for example in
the novels the hench person of
indeterminate gender is last seen at
Heimlich hospital where they likely died
in the fire and the bald man is eaten
alive by lions in the carnivore
carnival book in the TV show however
both those hench people are still part
of Olaf's troupe throughout the slippery
slope episodes as for the white faced
women on the Netflix series they abandon
Olaf's truth after he tells him to throw
Sonny off the mountain as he also did in
the tenth novel however in a change from
the books the bald man and the hench
person of indeterminate gender joined
the white faced women in quitting Olaf's
team and as they leave they discussed
their future plans which involve farming
and music halls and we last see them on
stage together at the end of a show
they've put on enjoying the audience's
applause unlike the members of olat
villainous theatre troupe the carnival
freaks last a lot less time in the TV
series than they do in the books in the
original stories Colette Hugo and Kevin
are still alive and kicking and very
much part of Olaf's wicked crew at the
Hotel de new mom and they even provide
evidence at Olaf and the Baudelaire
trial though it's unclear whether they
make it out of the hotel fire alive
however in the TV adaptation the former
carnival employees are bumped off in the
mortmain mountains by the man with a
beard but no hair and the woman with her
but no beard soon after the start of
season 3
I imagine this was done to gradually
chip away at Olaf and his schemes
bringing him down from his literal and
figurative highest point at the start of
the season and of course it also gives
us an insight into the show's two newest
villains during season 3 we also learn
more than we do in the books about count
Olaf's relationship to the man with a
beard but no hair and the woman with
hair but no beard
when Olaf first sees the ominous juror
in the TV show he calls the mummy and
daddy obviously we see Olaf's actual
father during the Opera flashback so
these two terrible people are not his
real parents but rather his figurative
parents or men's [ __ ] who recruited
him to their nefarious ranks when he was
at a low point in his life after the
death of his father by adding some
backstory between these two new
characters and Olaf in the show it gives
us some context to what led Olaf down
this dark fire filled path in life and
it's interesting to see how this man and
woman are so much more impressed with
esmi who they've never met before than
they are with Olaf who's so desperate
for their approval the TV series leaves
the Quagmire's and the widdershins on a
somewhat hopeful note with the quagmires
reuniting and Fiona infernal defining
list
father captain Witten's however the
books leave us on a much vaguer and less
optimistic note when it comes to their
fates in the novel's quickly does
reunite with his siblings and helps them
deal with the Eagle sent to attack their
self-sustaining hot air mobile home but
the birds managed to pop the balloons
sending everyone crashing into the
queequeg below which Rex the submarine
the widow shins and kit Snicket who was
on the sub at the time are all tossed
into the sea along with the Quagmire's
and Hector from the village of foul
devotees then the great unknown appears
and all of them apart from kit disappear
either swallowed up or rescued by that
mysterious thing the way the TV show
ends the Quagmire's and widdershins
stories gives fans a little more closure
which many have enjoyed though some
prefer a more unfortunate ending like
the books in the TV version of events
when a heavily pregnant Beatrice and her
husband Bertrand decide to leave the
island it's because they choose to
return home in time for the birth of
their first child violet as they realize
they can't shelter their family there
forever this is rather different from
the books where the couple are forced to
abandon the island after Ishmael arrives
and begins spreading fears among the
Islanders about Beatrice and Bertrand's
leadership Ishmael's background as a
founder of VFD and principle of Prufrock
prep is also new to the series as in the
books he simply a former member of the
FD and chemistry teacher these changes
were likely made because there's just
one episode to wrap up the whole story
and the mutiny against a Baudelaire
parents would have needed more build-up
to make sense as the Ishmael's new
backstory well that's very much in
keeping with the TV series which has
been dropping clues and adding
intriguing story lines about VFD since
the very beginning instead of bringing
the third and final season to a close
with violet Klaus sunny and baby
Beatrice sailing away from the island
leaving their fate ambiguous as happens
in chapter 14 of the last unfortunate
events book the Netflix series continues
past this point skipping ahead ten or so
years and shows Lemony Snicket receiving
a letter from his niece Beatrice
Baudelaire the second and meeting up
with her at a soda bar where she tells
him what happened to the Bois de leurs
after they left the island by continuing
the story like this the TV show is
taking a page out of another of Lemony
Snicket's books called the
eris letters which as well as
correspondence between lemony and the
Baudelaires mother also contains letters
from kits daughter Beatrice asking
Lemony for help tracking down violet
Klaus and sunny by the way I explained a
lot more about the TV show's ending
including the sugar-bowl VFD the schism
and much more in my ending explained
video you can tap in the top right to
watch that or click the link in the
video description now what did you think
of the changes in the TV series and what
are your favorite moments in the show
and the books let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this smash
that subscribe button a notification
bell so you don't miss any new videos
next up tapleft for a full breakdown of
season 3 or tap write for another video
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time you PK movie
lovers